I'm incredibly excited today because
we're launching something totally
different for the Reuben report this
week we're posting interviews with five
different YouTube personalities that's
right there's no clips this week just
hour-long sit downs every day with some
youtubers you know and some others that
I think you're going to want to know we
took the room and report independent
just three months ago I told you guys
that we made the move to our own studio
and production company because I wanted
to keep the Reuben report on YouTube we
had to make a decision to take our show
completely off youtube in order to grow
our audience on another platform but we
couldn't turn our back on our home and
this is our home not only is this the
place to find video content but there's
also an incredible community of people
here from all over the world over the
next five days i'll be talking to
someone in egypt someone in canada
someone right here in Los Angeles
someone in the UK and someone across the
country in Atlanta one of the things I'm
most proud of with what we've done here
at the rubin report is the comment
section on youtube I pretty sure that's
never been said before but it absolutely
is the truth while most comment sections
are littered with endless trolls and
haters we've built a real community here
filled with people from every walk of
life and every political ideology I'm
talking liberals conservatives
libertarians gay straight black white
asian whatever it is all supporting the
ideas of free-thinking and opening their
minds to differing opinions sure there's
some of the standard trolling here to
obviously but I find even the trolls
that we have are usually pretty good
natured if you're one of the people that
share our videos or comment right here
give yourself a pat on the back because
you built this community right along
with us as proud as I am of the work
that we've done here to illuminate
voices from across the political
spectrum and across the globe the most
amazing part of being a youtuber has
been connecting with other people
through the power of ideas it's not a
coincidence that the mainstream media is
crumbling just as
lying voices are getting stronger and
louder that doesn't mean that you can
trust all the online people but we
finally have more options to choose from
this is the true beauty of the Internet
we've removed the gatekeepers and now
have unfiltered access to people all
over the world we are changing the world
in real time through the power of ideas
there obviously was no shortage of
people to choose from when selecting who
I would chat with this week these five
people care about free speech logic
reason and yeah fighting the dreaded
regressive left if you're just being
introduced to these voices know that
they all have my stamp of approval and
if you know them already i hope you'll
enjoy seeing them in a whole new light
with no jump cuts or interruptions if i
know anything about youtube it's that
you've got to keep it short and sweet so
here we go the reuben report youtube
week begins right now
you